chrissy teigen and john legend have lost
their baby
following pregnancy complications the 34
year old who announced she was expecting
baby number three with her husband
in august was hospitalized over the
weekend
and shared the heartbreaking news with
fans on instagram wednesday night
posting several tear-filled pics from
the hospital room
including this shot of her and john
holding their son
quote we are shocked and in the kind of
deep pain you only hear about
the kind of pain we've never felt before
chrissy added that they were never able
to stop her bleeding
and couldn't give their baby the fluids
he needed
despite having multiple blood
transfusions
something she kept her fans updated on
along the way
so i had my first blood transfusion
which sounds so much more dramatic than
it is
it's just like an iv but except
not fluids it's
human blood the model also explained
that while they waited to name their
first two children
four-year-old luna and two-year-old
miles until after they were born
they already had a name picked out for
their third
quote for some reason had started to
call this little guy in my belly jack
so he will always be jacked to us jack
worked so hard to be a part of our
little family
and he will be forever to our jack i'm
so sorry that the first few moments of
your life were met with so many
complications
that we couldn't give you the home you
needed to survive we will always love
you
chrissy ended her post thanking fans for
their support
adding quote on this darkest of days we
will grieve
we will cry our eyes out but we will hug
and love each other
harder and get through it later chrissy
shared an emotional tweet
writing driving home from the hospital
with no baby
how can this be real while john simply
wrote quote
we love you jack chrissy's posts were
met with
overwhelming support from fans and some
of her famous friends
including kim kardashian who wrote quote
we are
always here for you and love you guys so
much
gabrielle union who has suffered several
miscarriages of her own
echoed kim in the comments writing we
love you guys
so much and we will be here for whatever
y'all need
always paris hilton wrote that her heart
breaks for the couple
while channing tatum told chrissy he is
sending so much love
you